[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum internationalen
frühschoppen an diesen sehr heißen
sommertag an dem man sich kalte wohnung
er herbeiwünscht als sie fürchtet und
doch muss sich die politik genau damit
jetzt beschäftigen wie kann die
versorgungssicherheit im winter
gewährleistet sein auch wenn der
ernstfall eintritt und putin gar kein
gas mehr liefern können dramatisch
steigende energiekosten abgefedert
werden europa und vor allem auch
deutschland stehen vor großen
herausforderungen
deutschland hat sich bei den
gaslieferungen größtenteils auf russland
verlassen 55 prozent des gases kamen
2021 von dort doch auch die anderen
eu-länder müssen gar sparen um über den
winter zu kommen ende juli einigen sich
die eu energieminister auf einen
notfallplan 15 prozent des gasverbrauchs
sollen die eu staaten freiwillig
einsparen immer wieder wird die
europäische solidarität betont dieser
geist der macht europa moment sehr stark
doch die gaskrise hat weltweite folgen
in den usa steigt die inflation auf
rekordwerte die notenbank muss
gegensteuern erhöht den leitzins es
droht eine rezession und mit sorge
blicken alle auf den winter ohne putins
gas die meister der westen die
energiekrise
das ist unser thema heute hier im
frühschoppen und das sind unsere gäste
für die usa ist bei uns politologin und
journalistin kathrin klug herzlich
willkommen und für großbritannien ist
bei uns wendelin von bredow sie ist die
leiterin des berliner büros von
economist und die europäische
perspektive bringt uns näher ralph sina
erst der ehemalige leiter des
hörfunkstudios in brüssel herzlich
willkommen und herzlich willkommen
andrej kurkow er ist aus der russischen
redaktion der deutschen welle bei uns ja
heckhoff ganz europa blickt mit sorge
auf diesen winter bevor wir darüber
sprechen wie der westen mit der energie
krise umgeht blicken wir mal auf die
situation in der ukraine vor allem auf
das atomkraftwerk präsidentin er hat
jetzt vor einer nuklearen gefahr für
europa gewarnt und auch
un-generalsekretär motorisch zeigte sich
zutiefst besorgt wie schätzen sie die
situation ein
es ist eine ernste situation aber wir
müssen verstehen was da los ist die das
akw ist von russischen toten besetzt und
sie schießen über den fluss hinaus auf
die andere seite und beschießt
ukrainische stellungen die dann nicht
erwidern können weil sie sonst gefahr
laufen
das kraftwerk zu treffen das wird
ausgenutzt von russischer seite
es wird auch von der ukrainischen seite
darauf hingewiesen dass das in einem
unglück enden sollte aber könnte aber
keine der seiten hat interesse dass es
zu einem unglück kommt auch nicht die
russische seite denn bei ungünstigen
windverhältnissen würde die comedy
annektierte von russland annektierten in
erster linie von einer wolke getroffen
werden außerdem man braucht dieses akw
oder so sehen anscheinend die pläne
russlands aus um die krim zu versorgen
das heißt russland braucht ein
funktionierendes akw will natürlich aber
den westen wie mit anderen mitteln auch
erpressen und den angst und schrecken
versetzen das wird selber war mit mit
dem weizen dasselbe war ist jetzt mit
dem gas also es ist auch ein weiteres
druckmittel um den west möbel zu machen
und eventuell in die richtung zu zwingen
die moskau heute genehm wäre genau
darüber sprechen wenn er im laufe dieser
sendung über die druckmittel verschluckt
die usa unterstützten die forderung nach
einer entmilitarisierten zone rund um
dieses atomkraftwerk und russland moskau
angekündigt man wolle kooperieren
halten sie das für glaubhaft es kommt ja
doch immer noch wieder zu angriffen ich
glaube an das wichtige ist erstmal das
angebot das der multilaterale rahmen
greift wir haben gesehen dass die
internationale energie kontrollbehörde
in wir in wien und natürlich auch die
kollegen der un sie haben den
generalsekretär angesprochen und die
amerikaner gerade in diesem bereich
gesprächsbereitschaft signalisiert haben
wo es eben größere auswirkungen haben
kann die weit über das land noch mal
hinausgehen ähnlich wie auch den weizen
deal also da wird immer mit signalisiert
einerseits ist russland natürlich nicht
zu trauen und deswegen sollte das
sollten diese gespräche niemals aufgehen
in größere verhandlungen die immer
wieder
[Musik]
angeregt werden aus verschiedenen seiten
aber das ist natürlich doch in punktuell
um große versorgung sicherheitsfragen
geben sollte also damit wird gezeigt
dass die internationale gemeinschaft
noch funktioniert aber wie gesagt dass
man russland weiterhin mit großer
skepsis zu begegnen hat es ist ja so
frau von bredow das ist wirklich genauso
wie herr gucke schon gesagt hat immer
darum geht ein stück weit auszutesten
wie weit kann man gehen immer wieder ein
droh und druckmittel zu benutzen
was glauben sie was steckt so zusagen
seitens der russischen seite dahinter
und wie kann der westen sich dem ging
war auch stellen ich glaube dass
das lade mir putins spielt ein
strategisches spiel nicht für ihn ist
das alles das sind alles teil von doch
auch erpressungsversuchen und und den
westen so weit wie möglich unter druck
zu setzen auf verschiedene ob das jetzt
mit dem gas ist mit dem akw mit den
weizen genau wie wir das erwähnt haben
und so muss man das auch sehen dass ist
dass es drin das ist reine strategie und
auch wenn putin nachgibt oder sich
verhandlungs
sich verhandlungen zu gemerkt sein ist
das auch wieder robben teil dieser
dieser dieser strategie seinen traum
eines wieder großen imperialen russland
das aufzubauen also man muss das glaube
ich eigentlich sehr zynisch sehen in die
situation gekommen ist der westen vor
allem deutschland weil die abhängigkeit
von russischem gas einfach so hoch ist
und putin natürlich dadurch durch das
drosseln von gaslieferungen was wir
jetzt sehen den westen in diese
situation gebracht hat rechnen sie damit
dass
jetzt dieses spiel so weiter geht oder
wie gehen sie in die nächsten monate was
glauben sie wie geht es weiter also ich
glaube ganz entscheidend wird sein ob
wir diesen putin
erpressungsversuchen und dieser
kriegsführung mit hilfe der energie als
eu etwas entgegensetzen können und wenn
wir den fehler der kogit krise
wiederholen und jedes land für sich
kämpft und wir die grenzen dicht machen
und sagen nee also ein weinglas kommst
du jetzt aber nicht ran böses
deutschland du hast mit gut in diese
verträge gemacht über jahrzehnte
sehenden auges sozusagen ins unglück und
jetzt sollen wir euch helfen das geht
nicht also wenn wir diese strategie
wieder erleben aus kurve zeiten dann hat
putin glaube ich in diesem herbst und
vor allen dingen in diesem winter eine
sehr starke position und zwar hat auf
dem papier die eu sich verpflichtet
einzusparen 15 prozent und b zusammen zu
halten im fall einer gas notfall lage
aber wir hören ja schon wie es konkret
läuft und man sagt nee also wir liefern
gar nichts mehr wir machen unsere
grenzen für gaslieferungen dicht
portugal und spanien die noch gar nicht
mal angeschlossen sind an das
europäische gasnetz sagen ohne uns seht
zu wie ihr klarkommt und es gibt ganz
viele signale auch aus polen die
aussagen einer nein unsere gasspeicher
in polen sind voll aber wenn ihr glaubt
wir würden das nach deutschland liefern
dann seid ihr schief gewickelt also es
deutet alles darauf hin dass putin in
diesem winter wirklich mit der eu ein
leichtes spiel hat und ich hoffe dass
ich das noch mal etwas enger wird nicht
ernst kurz da sind ja auch selbst dieses
abkommen dass er als großer fortschritt
verkauft wurde dass es sind ja nur dass
es nicht man die tri also es muss wie
immer muss es nicht mehr haben sondern
man begannen diese 15 prozent das heißt
im grunde kann jedes land machen was es
will also es ist das ist mehr oder
weniger eine absichtserklärung von der
mal war sehr leicht abweichen kann also
insofern kann das sehr sehr leicht
verbessert oder wurde eben schon sehr
verbessere richtig und man merkt es eben
schon dass man sah ich merke das auch
belgien wo ich eine lange gelebt hat die
sagen natürlich auch freunde in
deutschland wir haben uns nie in diese
abhängigkeit begeben ja also wir haben
dafür gesorgt dass wir gas aus den
niederlanden gekriegt haben aus
großbritannien gekriegt haben aus
norwegen gekriegt haben wir haben von
katar schiffe nach antwerpen schippern
lassen und nur minimal aus russland
bezogen ihr habt rang geklotzt billiges
gas und jetzt so häufig als kleines
königreich euch das liefern da sind wir
etwas zurückhaltend man kann es
natürlich psychologisch verstehen die
deutschen sagen in der eu moment mal
freunde ihr habt ja recht wir waren auf
dem falschen dampfer aber wie war das
denn als die griechen sich verschuldet
haben da haben wir geholfen was man mit
der euro krise mit der bankenkrise wir
haben euch immer geholfen und jetzt
endlich sind wie in der schwierigen
situation und er ist es endlich bezieht
sich auf eure hilfe jetzt sind wir dran
dass uns geholfen wird so wird da hin
und her gefunden aber das zeichen wenig
eindruck aber es ist natürlich gerade
die situation dass ein land wie polen
einfach auf sagt wir haben euch immer
gewarnt also jetzt in dem fall die
deutschen ihr wollte diese warnungen
nicht hören beschreiben sie mal aus
ihrer perspektive wie sie darauf blicken
also ich würde das nicht so düster malen
weil das ist ein sehr deutscher blick
die polen haben anfang mai ein
interconnect also eine leitung nach
liter und gelegt das heißt dass die
vollen speicher in polen und ab oktober
werden sie noch eine pipeline die baltic
pipe aus norwegen haben die polen werden
in diesem winter davon gehe ich aus
nicht deutschland retten wollen
was ja angesichts
der unstimmigkeiten gegenüber den nord
stream 1 und schon auf allem auf jeden
fall lotz den zwei ist aber sie werden
sehen werden lettland helfen sie werden
davon gehe ich aus estland helfen und
dadurch auch finnland weil die esten
haben
mit eu-geldern einer interconnect zu
finnland gebaut was ungarn angeht ungarn
ist ja ein sozusagen eine position und
ein problem weniger für die eu ich würde
als optimistischer sehen putin braucht
ungarn um zu zeigen passt auf ihr werdet
billiges gas haben wenn ja nur
prorussisch seit deswegen die versorgung
um ganz braucht sich die eu nicht zu
kümmern ein problem weniger so würde ich
das sehen das aber die polen tatsächlich
sagen wie konntet ihr in deutschland
dermaßen
lassen wir nach dem 1 2 bei seit aber
nach der krämer nexium die nord sind
zwei bauen und eure speicher gazprom
übergeben da muss ein bisschen mehr
also neue oder was auch immer von
deutscher seite kommen ja das war ein
großer fehler der deutschen politik und
jetzt auf die polen da sozusagen schief
zu schielen das wäre glaube ich nicht
angebracht denn und die erfahrung mit
den ukrainischen flüchtlingen hat
gezeigt die polen werden für die
osteuropäer meine feste überzeugung über
wiederhole ich noch mal in diesem winter
einstehen will ich dir ein zu sein dafür
ich verstehe die polen psychologisch
völlig dass die natürlich uns in
vogelsang und sagen hier hat mit diesem
verbrecher ständig deals gemacht obwohl
er die creme überfallen hat und obwohl
er schon 2007 energie als waffe
eingesetzt hat als er nämlich die
ukraine daran gehindert hatten polen und
andere mittel und osteuropäische staaten
zudem an sie zu liefern schon 2007 hat
putin energie als waffe eingesetzt das
hat frau merkel nicht daran gehindert
weiter nur zwei voranzutreiben also
psychologisch verstehe ich das völlig
nur meine deutsche perspektive wird
jetzt nicht daher dass ich in oberhausen
geboren bin und einen verengten
blickwinkel habe sondern wenn
deutschland
wirtschaftlich in schwierigkeiten kommen
com polen tschechien ungarn in massive
schwierigkeiten das heißt deutschland
ist in dem sinne wirtschaftlich die ja
ich gehe dahin geben soll jetzt aber
alle belgien und niederlande und die lng
terminals in diesen beiden ländern
versorgen ja deutschland das ja ja das
bild nicht versorgt an dem punkt für
dich gerne mal facebook einen ruhigen
momenten die runde weil das ist ja genau
der punkt auch zum einen das natürlich
in deutschlands wirtschaft nicht
funktioniert es auswirkungen hat auf den
rest aber auch noch mal den blick aus
den usa wie nimmt man das war weil auch
seitens der usa ja deutschland immer
wieder gewarnt wurde oder zumindest das
thema nord stream natürlich auch lange
zwischen usa und deutschland sehr
kontrovers diskutiertes hat natürlich
auch große innenpolitische auswirkungen
gehabt damals weil sowohl die regierung
obama wie auch die regierung beiden
haben eigentlich frau merkel den rücken
gestärkt
weil sie zumindest keine sie wollten
keine besucher wirken lassen nach
russland zwischen der deutschen und
amerikanischen seite aber wir erinnern
uns an den an den straßen stark sprach
fähigen kongress an einen trust der
immer wieder das korsett der sanktionen
gerade was nord stream zwei enger
gezogen hat so dass wir dann natürlich
schon die belegung der gerade auch der
quasi des umfelds von nord stream 2 mit
sanktionen aus den usa gesehen haben und
die schauen natürlich also ist da ist
natürlich jetzt dieses geschachere und
wir erinnern uns daran dass eben 20 21
das schon los ging gerade um diese zahl
zwei frage dass herr putin da am gashahn
saß und später im betrieb um quasi genau
diese und diese bruchstelle diese
transatlantische bruchstelle quasi noch
mal herauszufordern also genau wie war
vom rheder sagt er es ist das sind diese
strategischen spielen die ich auf
verschiedene ebenen sich abspielen
werden aber ich glaube auch innerhalb
der europäischen union muss man sich
natürlich überlegen wie weit quasi das
abstrafen in deutschland in
anführungszeichen gehen kann weil wir
eine kontraktion sehen wir eine
währungsfonds sagt na ja es kann dann
deutschlandweit über ein prozent
belasten in der belastung des disput
nach vorne und überlastungen die wir so
schnell nicht wieder reinholen können
werden die interdependenzen existieren
überall das heißt ganz europa hängt
natürlich umgekehrt auch von der
stellung deutschlands im europäischen
wirtschaftsraum ab das heißt da wird die
diplomatie wirklich interessant zu
schauen welche wie viel solidarität muss
sein was kann man dann quasi
argumentativ noch abstrafung so eine
abstrafung didaktik raushängen lassen
aber umgekehrt muss es ja darum gehen
alle durch den winter zu bringen denn
wenn man wie benjamin franklin sagen
würde wenn man nicht zusammen hängt wenn
realschule hengst bradley und das ist
glaube ich der fakt und das ist das
worauf wladimir putin wartet und das ist
auch das interessante wenn man jetzt auf
großbritannien blickt wo ja die
situation so ist dass man auf der einen
seite nicht so abhängig ist also gar
kein vergleich mit deutschland was jetzt
die situation mit russischem gas an geht
aber nichtsdestotrotz in großbritannien
schon einen notfallplan dahingehend
herrscht dass man sich bei gasknappheit
von organisierten stromausfällen
gesprochen wird sowohl in der industrie
als auch in privaten haushalten warum
trotz der nicht vorhandenen abhängigkeit
fürchtet man in großbritannien diese
engpässe als erstes ist einfach das auf
dem weltmarkt so furchtbar teuer
geworden das ist einfach schwierig also
soviel zu bezahlen und das zweite ist
eben großbritannien eigentlich keine
gasspeicher gibt so wie bei uns also das
thema ist jetzt glaube ich gar nicht
mehr so die energieknappheit für den
winter sondern einfach die inflation
also dass ich war jetzt gerade geändert
wird dann nur über die inflation
gesprochen und über natürlich wäre der
nächste premierminister wird also das
ist jetzt im moment das große thema und
das irgendwie es ist nicht so wie wir
sprechen wir hier jetzt sehr sehr viel
über den winter und das gas das ist
nicht so dass großes mehr die inflation
an sich bei uns wenn ich ein wort das
wort gasspeicher aufgreifen das mal so
sagen die briten haben so wenig wir
haben ja nun welche zum teil dem jahren
gast auch verhökert was ja auch
unglaublich ist aber ich entdecke bei
mir selber schon den irrsinn der sich
morgens gucke wie voll sind unsere
gasspeicher als wenn man die online
informations dienst sid dann meldet
heute glaube ich die zeit juhu 75,6
prozent er ist natürlich völlig banane
denn dieser gasspeicher fetischismus und
der glaube weil wir jetzt bei 76% und
ländern die bundesnetzagentur sagt und
dann haben wir 80 und 90 und dann wird
der winter easy das ist völliger
blödsinn diese gasspeicher decken ja in
der bundesrepublik nur ein viertel des
gesamten gas energie bedarf sie decken
gerade weil die hälfte dessen was wir
verheizen von der industrie ganz zu
schweigen die industrie ist aber noch
gar nicht drin also selbst wenn die
gasspeicher alle zu 100 prozent gefüllt
sind und ob nun mit oder ohne polnische
hilfe selbst dann ist es nicht easy wenn
gleichzeitig kein gas mehr fließt und
insofern ist dieser gasspeicher
fetischismus dass er da immer gucken und
denken auch wird alles ganz locker mit
vorsicht zu genießen wenn ich einmal
etwas hoffnungsvolles sagen da falle ich
ja nun aus dem ruhrgebiet kommen in
oberhausen geboren dessen groß geworden
eine der großen chemiekonzerne ist in
essen evonik ein spezialchemie
unternehmen da hat der chef kullmann
noch vor vier monaten gesagt das geht
hier dem herunter kein gas mehr forget
germany so jetzt vier monate später hat
evonik 40 prozent des erdgases ersetzt
durch flüssiggas
lng also dieses auto autogas lpg und
also dass das erdgas ersetzt durch
flüssiggas in wenigen monaten mit hilfe
von bp die in gelsenkirchen der eine
eine riesen fabrik aufgebaut haben mit
hilfe des chemieparks marl 40 prozent
ersetzt ohne dass die produktion leidet
das heißt es gibt hoffnung dass wir auch
mit erheblich reduzierten erdgas einsatz
durch ersatz durch substitution die
produktion aufrecht erhalten können und
da ist evonik ein großer hoffnungsträger
genauso letztes wort dazu basf lanxess
brenntag alle haben positive
gewinnerwartungen für dieses jahr wo am
anfang noch alle gesagt haben es gibt
die katastrophe zwei punkte dazu ich
wollte mal den punkt mit der mit
großbritannien aufgreifen weil nämlich
die preise also und das sieht doch mal
auf die frage energie diplomatie hin
einerseits haben wir als europäische
union mit dem vereinigten königreich
gerade drei verschiedene rechtsstreite
am laufen über das land irland protokoll
und umgekehrt war erhöhen die briten
gerade um ein drittel die punkt
geschwindigkeit der lng durch die durch
die pipeline in die niederlande also
weil es sich nämlich lohnt wir sagen da
werden auch einer werden auch bestimmte
wirklich kapitalistische einschätzungen
gemacht ja womit können wir jetzt hier
geld verdienen ist bei den amerikanern
genauso die amerikaner haben jetzt also
es wurde gesagt sie wollten ein drittel
die gaszufuhr nach europa weiter erhöhen
das haben sie ja fast verdreifacht nicht
weil es jetzt einfach nur in die
diplomatischen fragen reinspielt die ja
sehr wohl natürlich im vordergrund
stehen aber umgekehrt weil das einfacher
kapitalismus ist die gaspreise sind so
wie sie sind und umgekehrt ist glaube
ich das sehr spannend erstens zu sehen
zu sagen unsere industrie ist fähig
relativ schnell umzuschichten
aber das müssen wir wiederum aus den
früheren inflations perioden und aus den
früheren öl und gas krisen lernen oder
und die amerikaner das gerade mit diesen
großen gesetzespaket gelernt meiner
meinung nach oder schauen darauf dass
sie es lernen nämlich dass wir
einerseits in erneuerbare und andere
technologien investieren und ganz auf
großer fläche natürlich auch schauen wie
kriegen weil energie ist vielleicht eine
kurzzeit-lösung aber der der der co2
ausschuss und die das beantwortet nicht
die dekarbonisierung fragen die wir uns
alle stellen müssen das heißt es muss
sie gleichzeitig investitionen in die
alten fossilen brennstoffe kommen damit
wir einfach durchkommen durch die krise
aber gleichzeitig und das waren eben die
fehler die wir aus den 70er jahren
gelernt habe in diese neuen technologien
um das weiter zu denken denn da war
alles sauber im moment noch mal bei den
energy terminals glauben sie das kann in
diesem winter schon eine hilfe sein also
ich glaube zumindest jugend also die
tatsache dass die garde dass das
gasvolumen so unglaublich hoch gefahren
wird das ist schon hilfreich die frage
ist natürlich und das ist da sind wir
wieder bei den technologischen fragen
dass die das gas muss ankommen es muss
umgelagert werden und da sind wir haben
wir jetzt natürlich jetzt in dem in dem
anschauen der verschiedenen terminals
und der weiter leitungskapazitäten in
europa gemerkt da hinkt es noch und da
wiederum ist natürlich die europäische
solidarität gefragt und da wie gesagt da
dürfen die grenzzäune die gefühlten
nicht wieder hoch gehen sondern da muss
geschaut werden wie können solche die
kann das so um verlagert werden dass wir
kernindustrien und das wird genau diese
diese balance zu fragen stellen was sind
denn eigentlich die europäischen
kernindustrien levy retten müssen und
wie umgekehrt gehen wir mit den
einzelnen konsumenten um das sind die
ganz großen fragen jetzt für brüssel
aber brüssel nur eine wirkung ich habe
gemerkt wie ignorant ich selber war ich
wusste nicht das ist kein eu gas
binnenmarkt wir haben eine eu gasstrom
markt also der migrantenstrom aber es
gibt keinen eu gas binnenmarkt es gibt
keine regulierung es gibt keine röhren
wie gesagt spanien und portugal hängen
weitgehend draußen
irland ist nicht angeschlossen an das
europäische gasnetz malta ist nicht
angeschlossen zypern ist nicht
angeschlossen also schon technisch ist
es suboptimal und die die angeschlossen
sind da ist es nicht reguliert und das
habe ich auch als brüssel korrespondent
ihr gesagt nie beleuchtet oder nicht
ausreichend rückblickenden da merkt man
auch teilweise selber wie wir als medien
auch unsere blinden flecken hat nicht
nur frau merkel im kanzleramt
die uns erzählt er doch als
privatwirtschaftliches projekt wobei sie
wusste dass der ceo von atrium 2 ein
ehemaliger stasi majors also eine der
übelsten figuren aus dresden aber das
ist nur eine klammer wir merken auch wir
haben dazu wenig hingeguckt wie
funktioniert das eigentlich in der eu
und jetzt sind es fragen die wir uns
stellen die ja wirklich so sind dass man
sagt warum hat man darüber früher
eigentlich nicht nachgedacht
beispielsweise beleuchtung von gebäuden
oder sich zu hinterfragen wie weit
müssen eigentlich öffentliche gebäude
flure runtergekühlt werden in spanien
passiert da ja jetzt schon eine menge
wir diskutieren jetzt in jedem land was
kann freiwillig passieren selbst schon
angedeutet damit man diese 15 prozent
reduzieren kann das ist aber natürlich
ein freiwilliges momentum wirklich
überlegt wird vielleicht gehen wir da
noch mal kurz in blick darauf
was passiert wenn diese freiwilligkeit
nicht ausreicht dann gibt es also in
diesem abkommen das die eu länder
geschlossen haben also alle außer ungarn
haben ja dazu gestimmt es gibt so einen
trigger also man kann es ist im moment
alles auf freiwilliger basis aber wenn
die lage sich wirklich dramatisch
verschlechtert dann wird es nicht mehr
freiwillig dann dass es dann muss man
müssen die länder das machen aber da ist
eben die kritik dann gibt es so viele
lupus und so viele ausnahmen dass es
dann dass man sich dann doch auch da
auch da wieder raus könnte wenn man
wirklich wollen möglich ich glaube aber
genau was sie auch erwähnten das ist ja
erstaunlich wie die industrie sich
schnell angepasst habe ich finde dass
also basf evonik aber auch die
autohersteller die ganz großen
industrien hier die haben am anfang
gesagt um gottes geht überhaupt nicht
also der in ludwigshafen ist es riesige
basf werk und die haben gesagt nee also
wir können das überhaupt nicht ohne das
gas aus russland und jetzt heißt es na
ja also wir könnten bis 50 prozent von
wenn wir das noch bekommen dann kann das
sogar dieses werk noch weiter laufen
also das ist und ich glaube das geht für
privathaushalte auch also man kann dann
sehr viel mehr als man denkt sagt ich
nichts um so angenehm und und ich auch
nicht gerne eben nur neben zweiten tag
duschen oder was immer dann die ist
kommt aber ich glaube man kann also
sowohl privat wie auch die wirtschaft
kann sehr viel mehr als man sich das
noch am anfang des jahres vorstellen
konnte und das finde ich gibt anlass zur
hoffnung das ist natürlich genau der
punkt auf den wir im kern jetzt in
dieser sendung auch kommen wird dann die
solidarität da sein in ländern die
eigentlich für sich selbst genug gas
haben dann zu sagen ich verzichte damit
ein land wie beispielsweise deutschland
dann auch durch den winter kommt glauben
sie da wird also ich würde mich noch
zum wort fetischismus etwas und für mich
ist und für unser thema die meldung
dieses wochenendes diese 75 prozent ich
will daran erinnern dass
ende juli die bundesregierung gesagt hat
zum ersten september müsste das 75
erreicht werden am 14 august haben wir
das schon also das ist wenn wir die
hoffnungsschimmer auf diesen sollten
dann ist das eine der großen
hoffnungsschimmer reise es geht voran
das heißt die
richtzahl 85 prozent zum ersten oktober
also in einer halb monaten scheint
realistisch zu sein was nun will ich
auch eine lanze für die eu
brechen obwohl sie viel mehr mit der eu
zu tun hatten aus brüssel aber sie
hatten irland malta und zypern auf
gezählt das sind alles inseln deren
anschluss an das europäische gasnetz ein
gewisses problem darstellt wenn sie aber
schauen dass neben der verbindung die
ich schon erwähnt hatte zwischen polen
und litauen in diesem jahr auch die
verbindung zwischen griechenland und
bulgarien geschaffen worden ist so ist
ein die möglichkeit gas umzuleiten noch
größer geworden
beispielsweise im süden und russland
hatte ja bulgarien den gashahn abgedreht
weil bulgarien sich geweigert hat
mit den rubel also an diesem beispiel
dazu nicht und rummel zu bezahlen ist ja
in euro aber sich an diesem spiel zu
beteiligen und jetzt springen das ist
jetzt das thema was sie angesprochen
solidarität die griechen ein und sind
bereit und pumpen auf auch das
aserbaidschanische gas das über die
türkei nach griechenland kommen kunden
nach bulgarien also dieses finstere bild
dass jetzt alle europäischen länder
böse auf deutschland niemanden das gas
weg
übergeben das stimmt nicht es ist
vielleicht als populistisch zugespitzt
um eine problematik in denen er durch
die medien zu erzeugen und eine
sensibilität für diese problematik die
es ja da aber parallel dazu ist ein
umschichten von
gasmengen
durchaus zu beobachten und es gibt gute
beispiele ich glaube da sind wir alle in
der runde einer meinung gleichzeitig
gibt es den britischen notfallplan der
ja schon bevor sieht wenn es ganz hart
auf hart kommt dann keine lieferung mehr
zum europäischen festland
jetzt ist es natürlich mit
großbritannien auch eine besondere
situation facebook angesprochen
nichtsdestotrotz da kann man natürlich
jetzt sagen warum sollte großbritannien
da jetzt noch an der stelle so besonders
solidarisch sein aber auch
großbritannien steht natürlich vor der
frage wenn es keine speicherkapazitäten
gibt wurde das land ja auch auf die ein
oder andere art und weise auf das
festland angewiesen sein vielleicht doch
noch mal ein blick darauf dass stimmen
aber was immer groß bekamen im moment
entscheiden muss man natürlich auch
alles mit dem sich auf dragset nicht das
heißt also praxis und es geht um den
neuen premierminister und da wird
natürlich dieses wie erstmal für uns und
gegen und und leider wird ja brüssel
doch immer noch sehr als feindbild
aufgebaut jedenfalls von einem gewissen
teil der bevölkerung und auch von der
von der regierung nicht und ich glaube
man muss das irgendwie immer mit dieser
optik sehen das ist aber im grunde sitzt
auch großbritannien mit im europäischen
bot die sitzen ja eigentlich alle im
selben boot und das ist glaube ich ein
paar einigen noch nicht so ganz
angekommen richtig richtig also ich bin
ein optimistischer mensch herr gauck und
deswegen hab ich auch extrem sonnig
erwähnt und die industrie mit diesen
hervorragenden bilanzen basf lanxess
brenntag die alle sagen das jahr wird
wirtschaftlich gut so aber bei den
gasspeichern da muss ich sagen ich bin
ja gehör selber und freue mich dass wir
jetzt aber über 75 prozent sind aber ich
habe mir die bundesnetzagentur angeguckt
und jetzt studien gemacht
und die hat szenarien für diesen winter
durchgespielt und in sechs von acht
szenarien werden die gasspeicher der
laufen das heißt selbst wenn wir die
ganz tolle haben freuen wir uns aber
dürfen wir uns nicht in der falschen
sicherheit wiegen dass uns das durch
bringt in sechs von acht szenarien der
bundesnetzagentur laufen die speicher
leer es zum beispiel nur ein problem was
nicht undenkbar ist dass es cyber
attacken auf lng terminals gibt dass es
bei lng terminals zu problemen kommt die
laufen auf 100 prozent auslastung das
ist nicht ohne in diesen szenarien der
bundesnetzagentur ist noch gar nicht
eingepreist was ist wenn der winter hart
wird falls das noch jemals mal gibt und
so deswegen dass meine einzige es ist
toll dass die speicher sich zu füllen
nur lasst uns nicht zu fröhlich sein
nach dem motto jetzt wird alles easy an
den von fröhlichkeit kann keine rede
sein aber auch nicht von einem etwas
deutschen untergangs sozusagen film kein
realistischer optimismus ich bekenne mal
den blick auf jeden einzelnen ländern
das eine ist wie kann jeder einzelne
sozusagen sein verhalten seinen konsum
ein stückweit steuern aber natürlich
auch einfach die wahnsinnig stark
steigenden energiepreise wo ja noch gar
nicht klar ist wie drastisch das für den
einzelnen wirklich werden wird klar ist
habe ich spricht von einigen hundert
euro pro haushalt dazu haben eine frage
auf facebook von susanne beinhorn sie
sagt warum müssen wir für die fehler
unserer regierung aufgenommen und nun
noch zarten also ich glaube das ist der
grundsätzliche punkt was wir
eher als wir uns eingelassen haben vor
einigen monaten auf das spiel was bleibt
mir putin mit uns spielt nämlich dass
der panikmache ist es gefährlich nach
innen wenn man den bürgern nicht an die
hand gibt was sie selber tun können
außer dem baumarkt zu laufen und
irgendwelche sekundär heizöfen zu kaufen
die dann in nullkommanichts ausverkauft
waren tun wir uns keinen gefallen also
umgekehrt die tatsache dass wir diese
frisur gesehen haben innerhalb der
bundesregierung zwischen dem
finanzminister und dem
wirtschaftsminister das wirkt natürlich
auch die bevölkerung erst mal total dies
orientieren und ich glaube ganz ganz
wichtig ist jetzt zu sagen
eigentlich gibt es unglaubliche
kapazitäten erst wir haben über die
industrie gesprochen aber umgekehrt man
schaut sich jeder verbraucherzentrale an
auch die lokalen die haben eine
energieberatung
systematik die es seit jahren gibt da
kommen die leute zu ihnen nach hause und
beraten sie zu ihrer energie anlagen ich
meine diese dinge müssten eigentlich
umgekehrt ich bin eigentlich sehr beim
positiven narrativ weil ich glaube auch
team deutsche genetik entspricht dem er
an die panik zu glauben und dann
verfällt man in untätigkeit des stars in
diesem moment nicht passieren weil und
da bin ich ganz bei hansa diese
szenarien richtig ausgespielt werden
soll wir haben ja gesehen auch die
cyber-attacken die am anfang los ging
auf die ukrainischen strom und
versorgungswerke die dann im endeffekt
nicht funktional waren weil die
amerikaner und microsoft da das auch
umgekehrt alles schon vorher gesehen
haben und da einschreiten konnten aber
man muss auf jedem level jetzt sowohl
auf der 30.000 fuß politischen ebene
diese dinge vorsprung aber eben
umgekehrt hier der bevölkerung auch das
gefühl geben sie können selber aktiv
werden und da ist es eben und da darf
die politik die bevölkerung nicht
alleine lassen denn dass das lähmt
einfach und das wird das spielt wiederum
dem dem russischen diktator sagen wir es
ganz ehrlich in die hände aber wenn sie
sagen er ist panik und dann untätigkeit
ist das was wie sie auch den zustand
beschreiben würden der europäischen
politik ist gibt ja diverse ansätze um
sozusagen politisch so zu steuern
mit energiepreis wechseln oder der über
gewinn steuer es gibt ja ideen wie waren
sozusagen dem politisch entgegen wird
also die eu dass wir das muss man sagen
hat in rekordzeit wirklich gehandelt die
hat ja dieses konzept für sparen 15
prozent ein und im prinzip helfen wir
uns innerhalb einer woche beschlossen
das war ja so schnell ist noch nie ein
beschluss durchgeführt worden also wenn
man das positive hervor heben will jetzt
muss man gucken wie wird das konkret
werden wie wir diese solidarität
aussehen ich verstehe die frage da auf
facebook extrem gut weil ich immer noch
mal gerne frau merkel gefragt hätte wie
das eigentlich sein kann dass sie
gesehen hat dass 2007 2008 2009 putin
zum ersten mal erdgas als waffe
eingesetzt hat dass die krim 214
überfallen wurde und trotzdem so nord
stream 2 produziert hat wissen dass an
der spitze dieser behörde ein ehemaliger
stasi verbrecher aus dresden steht
namens matthias wanik der major bei der
stasi war der eine führende funktion in
diesen verbrecherischen system hatte und
die frage die ich als bürger
rückblickend ein frau merkel hätte wäre
wie sie eigentlich als ddr bürgerin die
ja das unrechtssystem stasi sehr genau
gekannt hat die wusste was bautzen war
ein projekt zu protegieren kann und als
privatwirtschaftlich ausgeben das von
jemand geleitet wird no 10 2 der der
ängste putin buddy in dresden war putin
kgb matthias war war nicht schade sei
absolut spannende
thematik ich würde gerne ganz kurz beim
beim ganz normal würde beim
endverbraucher bleiben um da auch
wirklich bei hin zu blicken weil
natürlich jeder sehr besorgt in diesem
winter blickt
menschen die nicht wissen wie sie genug
zum leben haben und natürlich einfach
diese höheren energiepreise gar nicht
abfedern können in großbritannien gibt
es ja tatsächlich schon zahlreiche
proteste und es gibt hab ich eine
kampagne die appelliert dass man die
rechnung nicht zahlen sollen erzählen
sie mal wie das in großbritannien gerade
ist ja das ist eine britische hat das
war auch werth während der pandemie gab
es auch eine kampagne dass man sagte
also irgendwas man wenn wenn man die
miete nicht mehr zahlen kann dann dann
dann darf der der familie das auch nicht
anfordern bis die pandemie zu ende ist
also muss die mieter da lassen also dass
das kommt immer wieder weil natürlich
mehr familien glaube ich noch alles
jetzt wirklich immer am anschlag geben
immer noch so page at paycheck immer
noch so gerade hinkommen und wenn dann
plötzlich noch so eine sehr viel höhere
energierechnungen schaffen sie es
einfach wirklich nicht und daher glaube
ich kann man das erklären das sind
einfach das sind notrufe nicht und und
also ich habe viel verständnis wie das
dann im endeffekt aussehen wird ob das
man wirklich machen kann also oder ob
dann die regierung einspringen wird das
ist mir nicht ganz klar aber
verständlich ist es allemal und jetzt
ist es ja so dass man in großbritannien
wahrscheinlich noch nicht an dem punkt
ist wirklich zu überlegen wie begegnet
man dem konkret sei ausgeschildert es
gibt themen auf der insel die erstmal
noch vordergründig sozusagen klar sein
müssen vielleicht mal aus ihrer
perspektive die ideen die es gibt um die
bürger zu entlasten
ist passiert da genug wird da schnell
genug aus ihrer sicht agiert oder
müsste es auch da vielleicht
einheitliches europäisches vorgehen
geben ich glaube nicht dass da
europäisches gemeinsames vorgehen ist
weil die situation an dass es spanien
ist in einer anderen situation als als
deutschland über eine energietechnische
und hat dann auch andere probleme die
die man mit anderen mitteln
lösen kann also erstens ich habe nicht
das gefühl dass die deutsche
gesellschaft nicht bereit es dieses
problem zu lösen ich sehe wie die
deutsche gesellschaft sehr besonnen die
pandemie durchgemacht hat obwohl man
auch auf etwas verzichten musste und
zwar auf viel mehr verzichten musste auf
freiheiten
was man jetzt in dieser krise nicht dort
habe man wird auf etwas mehr weniger
heißes wasser verwenden und etwas
weniger heizen aber nicht auf all die
freiheiten
die freiheiten verzichten müssen und
trotzdem war die gesellschaft bereit und
die solidarität in der deutschen
gesellschaft hat funktioniert was die
hilfsangebote bzw die hilfe angeht gut
ich habe als deutscher steuerzahler auch
das gefühl diesen 300 euro die uns da
versprochen worden sind hätten nicht im
september sondern vielleicht früher
kommen können und ich glaube auch dass
man
dieses diese messages die jetzt ja
kommen auch vom kanzler wir werden
mittel und wege finden euch das zu
kompensieren dass man das etwas intensiv
ii zieren sollte aber die idee dass die
leute sparen sollten ich habe das gefühl
nicht nur die wirtschaft die große würde
sondern auch der in die haushalte ich
habe auch das gefühl dass das angekommen
ist schon mal dass ich auch sehr
vernünftig ist man wenn man energie
spart
ist es nicht nur etwas gegen den krieg
und gegen putin zu ordnen auch für das
eigene portemonnaie und das ist sehr
überzeugend das müsse beibehalten werden
also muss die motivation zum sparen auf
jeden fall erhalten bleiben das ist die
krippe bei allen helfen dass das nicht
erzwingen doch jetzt kann ich ja doch
hemmungslos duschen und welchen
thermostat der heizung habe ist auch
ganz egal und so weit also das ist die
krippe ich glaube eines
sollte man nicht tun gerade wenn man auf
konzerne guckt wie evonik und andere
basf die jetzt so viel versuchen neues
zu machen und für wasserstoff wichtig
sind und für die neuen technologien
jetzt mit geschichten wie über gewinn
steuer kommen und denen das wegnehmen
das schafft eine enorme
investitionsunsicherheit für deutschland
da werden sich diese konzerne dreimal
überlegen ob sie noch hier und die
brauchen wir dringend also so sehr man
das psychologisch nachvollziehen kann
wenn man sieht rwe was machen die für
einen riesengewinn und ich muss bei
meiner gasrechnung jetzt soviel bluten
das ist doch nicht gerecht da nimmt doch
rwe was weg
psychologisch zu verstehen ob das
wirtschaftlich klug ist dadurch ein ganz
großes fragezeichen
es ist in der tat so letzter satz
konzerne die im moment strom erzeugen
mit regenerativen energien machen
gigantische gewinne warum weil sich der
strompreis ausrichtet an der teuersten
erzeugung durch gas das heißt die gastro
die die leute mit gas strom herstellen
die setzen die preislage fest und die
licht natürlich weit höher als bei denen
die gar kein gas brauchen für den strom
weise nämlich sonne nehmen oder wind das
heißt die fahren im moment wahnsinns
gewinne ein da zählt rwe dazu zählen
aber auch windparks und solarparks und
das erzählt auch der start der natürlich
über die steuer auch mehr als ich was
aber ja auch der plan ist dieses geld
durch gleich hat beim bürger ankommen zu
lassen wieder die situation im usa ist
nicht direkt vergleichbar weil die
inflation in den usa ja nicht über die
hohen energiekosten so massiv gibt
regiert wird wie jetzt
europa nichtsdestotrotz hat ja beiden
gerade dieses gesetz erlassen was ja
genau zur inflationsbekämpfung dienen
soll und die inflation ist in den usa ja
eher so dass man sagt vielleicht ist
eine vorsichtige trendwende zu erkennen
das ist finde ich trotzdem noch mal
interessant im vergleich zu sagen ist
das schon der weg in den usa um in eine
andere etwas weniger
sorgenvolle zukunft zu blicken naja es
ist zumindest geplant diese
umstellungsprozess durch den staat sehr
zu unterstützen und das ist vielleicht
noch mal in diesem kontext zu
unterstreichen was wir hier besprechen
sind eingriffe des staates in
energiemärkte und ich glaube das ist
schon mal ein punkt der sich generell
als globaler trend fest setzen lässt
also während man lässt die energie
mächte und die kartelle fleisch weil wir
mehr auf den etwas schlecht
ausgegangenen besuch von präsident biden
in saudi arabien gesehen der auf
vielerlei hinsicht schwierig zu
beurteilen ist oder beziehungsweise
diplomatische fallstricke hatte aber
umgekehrt ist jetzt klar dass einfach
wir viel mehr staatseingriff sehen
werden und das was wir und das ist
umgekehrt natürlich auch alles in diesem
gesetzespaket drin zu sagen wir machen
eine steuerliche vergünstigung wir
intensivieren den längerfristigen
technologie umbau die investitionen in
nachhaltige energien und und und und und
und überlegen so über steuer umlagen wie
wir quasi bestimmte effekte wieder
abfedern das ist natürlich für eine
gesellschaft die individuell gesteuert
ist wie die usa natürlich schon ein
massiver eingriff eine massive
veränderung deswegen wird herr beiden
jetzt auch wieder im kontext von allen &
johnson genannt der natürlich innerhalb
von den ersten zwei jahren seiner
präsidentschaft auch große
gesellschaftliche umbau pakete auf den
weg gebracht hatten wir erinnern noch
mal daran dass das paket was jetzt in
den usa verabschiedet worden ist freitag
durch den kongress noch mal bestätigt
worden ist
minimal dessen volumen also an an steuer
umlagen und an geldern hat was
ursprünglich vorgeschlagen worden ist in
dem bild besser planen das heißt wir
sehen eine usa die sich immer noch ab
kämpft mit der unterstützung von
fossilen energien die für die
amerikanische wirtschaft ganz
grundsätzlich wir haben über die
überproduktion gesprochen wer die großen
amerikanischen energieunternehmen dann
implizit gesprochen die sehr sehr viel
geld erwirtschaftet haben was eben auch
wichtig ist aber dann zu sagen man geht
doch mit unternehmenssteuer an große
amerikanische unternehmen rund 15
prozent das wird dem kanzler im ohr
geklingelt haben dass wir dann nach
steuern uns eher einen globalen standard
annähern also dass wir generell eine
situation sehen wo diese regierung
beiden sehr viel mehr eingreifen möchte
in die privat wirtschaftlichen
verhältnisse und wir haben umgekehrt
gesehen in der verhandlung dieses
paketes und da musste er mit demokraten
verhandelt werden im senat und nicht mit
republikanern das ist darum gehen genau
diesen punkt festzuhalten fossile
brennstoffe die herr menschen der der
senator der problematische senator für
die demokraten für seinen staat durch
bringen wollte immer noch genauso die
unterstützung haben musste pipelinebau
wie zb jetzt der und die umstellung für
nachhaltige energien also und dass
dieses phänomen das wird sich das werden
wir überall im westen sehen und
umgekehrt wiederum ein nachdenken
darüber wie energie diplomatie im
globalen umfeld aussehen kann und muss
und mit wem man dann langfristig reden
muss und ob das noch bequemer partner
sind oder eben nicht darf ich vielleicht
noch ganz kurz auf die frage von
facebook noch mal so zu sagen warum muss
müssen wir zahlen jetzt für die fehler
der politik nicht das hat ihr die dame
gefragt und im grunde es ist schon
erstaunlich wenn man sich nochmal die
ihrer merkel angucken frau merkel hat
glaube ich zwei ganz große fehler in der
energiepolitik einerseits gemacht
einerseits den ausstieg aus der
atomkraft und dass sie das nord stream
zu dieses projekt das im jahre jahre und
wurde immer kritisiert von amerikanern
kritisiert von einem hohlen kritisiert
einfach da man sagt ja die
privatwirtschaft damit haben wir nichts
zu tun weil es sehr klar dass das auf
der anderen seite hat sie nach der
annexion der krim hat frau merkel ihr
die ganzen eu eigentlich dazu getrieben
die sanktionen
also der sanktionspaket es auch ihr zu
verdanken als sie hat eigentlich putin
nicht unterstützt oder falsch
eingestellt ist deshalb das ist fast
noch paradoxer
jetzt stehen wir vor dem scherbenhaufen
und ich glaube die ganze energie
diplomatie von deutschland von usa von
sehr vielen ländern es ist ein riesen
umdenken das jetzt einfach durch dazu
wurden gezogen aber im grunde könnte das
resultat sehr positiv seien in ein paar
jahren aber da sind jetzt eine gegen
dürre und schwierige jahre die uns vor
uns liegt das ist das war nicht ein ein
winter und ein mittelschweres jahr nicht
ja aber es war ja gut der internationale
währungsfonds würde sich jetzt mit ihnen
abarbeiten aber der punkt ist das stand
ja auch im hinblick der das des beiden
pakets vis á vis der eu wir in uns daran
dass im märz will den handschlag gesehen
haben wenn man so will von ursula von
der leyen und dem amerikanischen
präsidenten zu sagen wir müssen
transatlantisch eben den schulterschluss
noch mal suchen das energie abkommen
quasi absichern und gemeinsam überlegen
und daher eben auch diese erhöhte zufuhr
von flüssiggas nach europa wie wir quasi
den wind aus den segeln nehmen umgekehrt
dürfen aber jetzt nicht vergessen dass
wenn soviel flüssiggas nach europa
gebracht wird von den amerikanern
wer dachte daran die ihnen da
südostasien und das wiederum macht ein
fass auf wie wir die phalanx in
anführungszeichen gegenüber china halten
also all diese fragen dürfen wir nicht
losgelöst voneinander sehen und da haben
beide regierungen beiden und natürlich
die kommission in brüssel gesagt das
erste wichtige ist diesen baustein zu
legen für die transatlantische
kooperation und dann umgekehrt weiter in
die welt zu schauen dass da diesen
zusammenhalt zu sehen um dann nicht
china die er nun billiger billiger
energie aus russland beziehen und indien
genauso in vorlage zu treten die
wiederum dann wohl alle teile
volatilitäten
aufwachen lauf machen in asien
südostasien und im südchinesischen meer
absolut und die letzte viertelstunde im
internationalen frischer und die gehört
ja immer den zuhörern und den
zuschauerinnen vielleicht bevor wir zu
den fragen kommen noch mal eine ganz
kurze sache die uns auf facebook
erreicht hat andreas wetzel fragt der
verzicht auf russisches gas ist von
deutschland ein eigentor wieso sollen
die sanktionen bei russland irgendetwas
bringen ergo kopf
sanktionen können den krieg nicht
stoppen sie können auch ein
totalitäres oder diktatorisches regime
nicht ändern das haben wir an mehreren
beispielen gesehen aber sie können die
fähigkeiten dieses regimes schwächen
einen krieg zu führen oder in weiteren
zu planen und das ist das wichtigste
dabei ferner die absage an das russische
gas ist nicht nur eine verkleinerung der
deviseneinnahmen
von russland
sondern auch
das rausschlagen aus den händen von
putins dieses instrumentes mit dem air
europa teilen erpressen
die ungarn zu sich ziehen und und die
deutschen vor den kopf stoßen kann
deshalb ist es wichtig und deshalb muss
das geschehen obwohl das mit gewissen
schmerzen die ich nicht überbewerten
würde
zumindest für einen großteil der
bevölkerung einher gehen danke schon mal
dafür und wir hören mal was sousa graue
aus berlin für eine frage an die runde
hat
ja schon mal hinrunde oder graue hier
ich bin immer in dieser ganzen
diskussion ums paare irritiert wie
schwer wir uns gerade deutschland bis
mitte
jahr mit irgendwelchen zumutung tun mit
vermeintlichen zu gut um die wirklichen
zugute sind ja waldbrände und ihre ganze
konsequenz von dem klimawandel und von
diesen ganzen geschichten paarung sachen
wird nicht einfach in spanien zum
beispiel regeln auch sofort bedient
gesetzte vorzugeben auf wie viel grad
zum beispiel jetzt in den supermarkt
runtergekühlt werden kann mal war der
mann ist hier dass hier in dem bereich
immer noch wahnsinnig rausgeholt wird
und mir sagt
im kalten sitzen ich fühle mich auch
manchmal wie der personifizierte applus
titel sind nicht da irgendwie aguirre
und valter wache und woanders wird immer
noch häufig
gehandelt und das finde ich irritierend
und ich glaube dass man den deutschen
viel mehr zu
gut ist dann zwar graue obwohl
wirsberger bitte warum tun wir uns so
schwer damit ich glaube es fehlt eine
charismatische politische figur die
diese herausforderung die auf uns
zukommen via stromrechnung via
gasrechnung et cetera
sozusagen graben nennt die nicht
verniedlicht sondern sagt ja das wird
hat und es wird gasrechnungen geben die
drei vier fünf mal so teuer sind wie
bisher und das sind immense hätten die
auf viele familien bis in den
mittelstand hinein zu kommen aber das
ist die situation mit der wir umgehen
müssen und die alternative kann nicht
sein weiter putins kram zu beziehen und
ein völkermörder zu unterstützen und das
wird aus meiner sicht wenig
wir müssen anfangen denn der punkt ist
ja der dass darwin im europäischen
kontext dass die deutschen wollen es zu
69 prozent
das hat man bertelsmann umfrage gezeigt
aushalten denn sie verstehen sehr wohl
im amerikanischen st freedom ist frei es
geht hier wirklich darum unsere art und
weise zu leben unsere demokratischen
system in dem pluralismus zu verteidigen
gegen die übergriffig kite der
russischen föderation und das nochmal in
den vordergrund zu stellen zu sagen das
ist das was es uns kosten wird und hier
sind aber wiederum die positiven
möglichkeiten das auszugleichen sowohl
aus staatshand aber eben auch mit
appellation an die eigenverantwortung
und den entsprechenden tools die man an
die hand geben das wäre doch die
strategische schleife ich glaube der
wirtschaftsminister versucht sich daran
kommt das an dass die frage hören wir
mal die nächste frage und zwar von
alexander covers aus aachen geht morgen
ja guten morgen ich habe eine frage die
bürger wir brauchen bestimmte leistungen
zum beispiel strom in eine wohnung heute
gab es heute in der dankesrede benzin
für mein auto und diese leistungen die
werden hier ausschließlich von privaten
firmen bereitgestellt
und die können jetzt hier natürlich
exorbitante gewinne zu reden möchte
nicht sagen dass sprachen gibt die kann
man also nicht überhaupt nicht
nachweisen aber die prinzipien und
leistung frage ist rollende der stadt
ist da um die interessen der bürger
nicht interessen der firmen zu vertreten
warum gibt es die möglichkeit dass der
staat sich signifikant an einer firma
beteiligt heute vielleicht eine eigene
gründet muss natürlich also dann erstmal
mit deckel finanziert werden durch
anleihen und dann ist der staat jahre am
markt mit realistisch niedrigen preisen
der durch schenkte die anderen von ihren
über gewinnen zu verzichten ja danke
herr karas für die frage wer mag
vielleicht
es ist durchaus eine idee und ich meinen
der staat er ist ja schon eingesprungen
möchte also bei ihm
also dass das kann auch und glaube ich
die gazprom germania hat der staat aus
naja wer sie insofern im grunde passiert
das schon und das wird unter umständen
noch ausgeweitet werden also durchaus
eine idee aber der hörer aus aachen hat
gesagt all die geschichten die ich
beziehe strom gas benzin werden ja von
privaten firmen bereitgestellt da muss
man nur eins hinzufügen das russische
erdgas wird von gazprom bereit gestellt
natürlich ist das eine firma aber es ist
natürlich eine putin firma und es ist
eine kriegskasse und insofern kann man
das nicht als privatfirma sagen und das
was wir erleben werden dass unsere
stromrechnung explodieren werden im
nächsten jahr und unsere gasrechnung
oder jetzt schon explodieren das geht zu
einem ganz großen teil auf dem gas plant
zurück gazprom kostet uns mit seiner
politik 200 milliarden euro das ist der
wahnsinn und das ist nur ein pseudo
konzern in wirklichkeit ist es ein
instrument wie wir wissen
nun damit wir möglichst vielen
zuschauern die gelegenheit geben ihre
fragen loszuwerden frau tütchen aus
meerbusch gut morgen
energie
energie plus biogasanlagen also
beanspruchen dann auch selbstständig
sind uns auch ohne studium unabhängig
sind von irgendwelchen zahlungen ja weil
das gemeinde finanziert wird jetzt frage
ich was will das in kleinen gibt kleine
möglich ist ist es sich auch wirklich
erst im großen anzustrengen damit man
autark ist und
von dem man dann als unabhängig ist ja
danke fürs moment ich hab noch etwas und
dann noch etwas
ist es nicht auch unklug ängste zu
schüren
auf die art und weise wird der preis
hochgetrieben und dann das einfach
gelassener zu sehen ja nein danke frau
teilt ihn der mag ja antworte ich glaube
es für die amerikaner da ist das schon
seit jahren ein hehres ziel sie haben es
natürlich lange also die die
unabhängigkeit natürlich wie gesagt ein
cl obama trump die energieunabhängigkeit
ein ganz wichtiger eckpfeiler immer in
der in der eigenen in der eigenen
domestic policy umgekehrt aber und das
nämlich noch der punkt dazu geht es
herrn beiden jetzt auch als nachgegangen
oder nachsatz zu diesem unglaublich
großen gesetzespaket das ist jetzt eben
gerade durch den kongress geschaffen hat
auch dazu zu überlegen wie kriegen wir
eigentlich preis regulatorien oder
gemeinsamem mechanismen hin um gerade
auch den den preis um einen quasi ein wo
ein preis boden hinzubekommen für
flüssiggas denn natürlich einerseits
freuen sich amerikanische unternehmen
deren gewinnspannen marge hoch hoch
gegangen sind aber das ist natürlich für
die welt nicht verträglich und das ist
eben für diesen wettlauf zwischen
demokratien und autokratien nicht
verträglich also da ist liegt das
angebot des amerikanischen präsidenten
auf dem tisch ich glaube da ist eben
auch ein großer zugang für die
europäische kommission dazu sagen da
muss man nachjustieren da sollte man
gemeinsam darüber nachdenken gibt es
sowas wie preis regulationsmechanismen
zu bestimmten energieformen unabhängig
jetzt von der opec die wir längerfristig
durchsetzen können aber wiederum passt
das in diese größere phänomenologie dass
man das eben nicht mehr der
privatwirtschaft unter überlässt sondern
wirklich jetzt der staat im erweiterten
sinne und im größerem sonne eingreifen
wird um einer staats gesteuerten ja
sagen wir gazprom maria gegenzusteuern
aber die dame hat er gefragt ob wir
nicht autark sein können ich finde das
einen ganz guten denkansatz und es wird
ja mehr investiert in erneuerbare
energien und das wird - investiert in
wind und solar und das ist ja ein
versuch genau das also autark werden wir
nicht aber autark im europäischen sinn
als
das würde ich sozusagen ergänzen das
wäre die deutschland-auftakt eigentlich
trainieren die eu auf dass das ein
projekt das durchaus realistisch ja ja
ich kann mein ganzes leben
nächsten zuschauer und zwar kein riedel
aus geesthacht
gibt es tatsächlich einen ganzen so ein
bisschen verwirrt klar wir haben jetzt
die problematik mit der gaslieferung wir
haben die klima thematik und so aber
müssten industrie politik und sonst noch
einfluss nehmen könnte dann viel mehr
hinterher sein dass wir mal von diesen
fossilen brennstoffen loskommen denn wir
sind ein bisschen meiner schule
aufgepasst hat der sollte sich doch
darüber bewusst sein dass das ganze zeug
irgendwie endlich ist das heißt auch so
wird immer gewinne einfahren möchte muss
man doch wege finden das muss zu kommen
ja also das spricht mich sehr an und
dass es auch die sache die mich
persönlich etwas macht das natürlich die
industriekonzerne seit langem wussten
die grenzen des wachstums sind erreicht
die klima gefahren sind da und trotzdem
sehr hemmungslos auf den alten pfaden
weiter gegangen sind und dass wir jetzt
als bürger
kurzer duschen
niedriger temperieren und so weiter
sollen also das finde ich ist schon auch
ein in der tat ein ungleichgewicht und
von daher finde ich es gut dass jetzt
große konzerne endlich wie basf mit
brudermüller an der spitze wie evonik
und andere jetzt ernsthaft überlegen wie
können wir umstellen muss sagen sie
haben lange zeit nicht sehr
verantwortlich da gehandelt und wir
sozusagen sind jetzt die die dann auf 17
grad runter und nur noch jeden dritten
tag duschen und auch nur mit duschbad
kopf und endlich neue thermostate und
weiß senger weiss also das finde ich
auch schon ist etwas eine eine um
balance das ist auch etwas was rainer
baumann anmerkt er schreibt wo wären die
preise für strom und gas heute wenn sich
die ampel regierung seit märz klar zur
atomkraft im biostrom der wasserkraft
und dem fracking erkannt hätte
vielleicht auch noch ganz kurz eine
einschätzung dazu fracking ist natürlich
gerade den usa ein ganz anderes thema
mathematisch aber natürlich jetzt immer
noch als ich meine da ist der
innenpolitische konflikt in den usa
vorgegeben die republikaner die immer
noch sehr stark an die zukunft der
fossilen energien glauben und die von
vornherein jetzt auch schon angekündigt
haben und zum teil auch auf gouverneurs
ebene dass sie quasi gegen das grosse
gesetzespaket auf unterschiedliche art
und weise zum teil perfide dagegen
steuern werden da geht um investitionen
da gibt es eine ganze pensionen und
renten pläne von
bundesstaaten investiert in die öl und
gasindustrie das heißt sie haben gesagt
also dass die frage des hörers setzt
voraus dass wir alle glauben dass es um
nachhaltige energien gehen muss das ist
das programm der eu fit for 50 5 ja aber
das ist noch nicht mal im globalen
gesagt das heißt also noch noch lange
haben die fossilen energien noch nicht
ausgedient die frage ist wie kriegt man
jetzt diesen umschlag hin und wenn man
auf biomasse geht dann sind ja auch
gleich bei dem zusammenhang mit dem mit
dem weizen problemen und den
verschiedenen anderen abhängigkeiten
also das muss immer im ganzen und auf
einer erhöhten ebene gesehen werden dass
wir diese umschlag bewegung wirklich
hinbekämen eu und transatlantik zusammen
aber es geben für mich
jetzt noch eine
den usa frank becher aus kulanz bei
einer frage an uns hat guten tag ich
muss mich ja der kopf fassen ich zitiere
aus dem tagesspiegel
sagte die kämpfe müssen dringend vor der
heizperiode beendet werden matt ist der
chef des präsidialamts in der ukraine
sonst bestehe das risiko dass russland
die infrastruktur für wärme und energie
zerstöre das ist einer der gründe
weshalb der maximale maßnahmen ergreifen
müssen um den aktiven quartal des
krieges bis ende herbst zu beenden hinzu
kommen noch die ukraine wird ja mit
begabten über den reverse flow versorgt
also letztlich auch von russland was
passiert denn wenn russland den gashahn
abdrehen ja dank habe ich ja noch mal
für diesen blick auch in die ukraine
ja also hier geht es
eindeutig um die ukraine ja das nicht
dass es missverstanden wird dass es zu
einer zerstörung der infrastruktur
in europa in der eu europa kommen würde
ja das ist ein sehr ernstes problem
die ukraine bezieht kein gas aus
russland bezieht gas aus europa und da
werden die europäer helfen und da wären
wir wieder bei polen und da gehe ich
davon aus dass auch die polen helfen
werden die ukraine
mit gas zu
beheizen aber für die ukraine wird
dieser winter unvergleichbar härter
werden jetzt abgesehen von von den
kriegsfolgen nur in der energiefrage in
der wärme frage wird unvergleichbar
schwieriger werden als für deutschland
und den rest europas hier sind auch
schon damit fast am ende der sendung
deswegen vielleicht kurze abschlussrunde
für die ukraine steht ja im mittelpunkt
wird es eine solidarität im westen geben
damit man ohne putins gas im ernstfall
auskommen könnte vielleicht noch mal
ganz kurzes abschluss statement also ich
glaube von von jerusalem ganz ohne frage
und man kann nur den hut ziehen vor
ländern wie polen gerade die so viele
flüchtlinge aufgenommen haben diesen
dabei schwer aber ich glaube dass in
sachen in der gpu begreift putin will
die ukraine im winter frieren lassen er
vermied die gelände um heizkraftwerke er
macht atomkraftwerke das größte
atomkraftwerk europas zum ziel das ist
ein ziel und das müssen wir auf jeden
fall verhindern
danke ich ihm die sind leider am ende
der sendung für diese diskussion und ich
danke ihnen fürs zu sehen und zu hören
und wir wünschen ihnen jetzt noch einen
schönen verbleibenden rest sonntag
[Musik]